yo what is up everybody mad Luigi here
again with another Dark Souls 3 video in
this video I'm going to be talking about
my thoughts about what the ring city DLC
is going to be like and I'll mainly be
focusing on Laura thoughts but there
will be a little bit of gameplay ideas
too I won't be focusing on the item
descriptions and images and trailers
because there are already a ton of
analysis videos and that stuff and this
video is going to be more of about my
opinion and hopes if you guys want me to
do a video about analysis and let me
know alright so the main topic that kind
of in case is all further discussion in
this is going to be how much of a series
level conclusion are we going to get
this is the last piece of Dark Souls
content that is ever going to be
released and there are million things
that are still ambiguous and date I
expect that the end will still be both
of these things to some extent but I'm
personally hoping for a higher level of
conclusion and tying of loose ends then
we usually get I think this is somewhat
justified because as I said this is it
if there's ever a time for the from crew
to give us a little more clarity and
this is it what we know about the DLC
starting and drag sheep should help push
this theme of final conclusion as all
the places of the Dark Souls franchise
melding together in one point is serious
symbolism for one final shebang I'm also
pretty hopeful for the DLC content wise
now don't get me wrong ashes of aerion
dough was a really fun DLC but it really
only had one awesome boss fight and it
wasn't that long before all from what
we've seen about the DLC in terms of
slight early release too popular content
creators and data mining it looks like
we're going to get a fairly long boss
Phil DLC which is exactly where I think
we all look forward from from dark souls
DLC going back to lower all the laundry
references in the trailer do pretty much
confirm there's going to be a lot of
lower progression in that field and this
could intertwined is a lot of other
things like velka the undead in general
an explanation of the Lord of launder
ending and explanation of what any age
without the fire link is like I think
we'll definitely get some information on
this one twilly some extent
in addition to all that lon door and the
funky son do also give some credence to
the thought that we're going to be
progressing the lower of the Dark Soul
and that could mean some more furtive
pygmy knowledge maybe throughout all of
this there is a good chance that we'll
get kind of just wrecked by from and get
an ending without much explanation or
satisfaction I'm betting that whatever
we get is going to have some elements of
that I don't think from will completely
illegal in the dark but there's a big
chance and we know the ending has to be
ambiguous and confusing in any case as
this wouldn't be dark souls of the lower
was straightforward and simple and it
wouldn't be nearly as fun if it was that
way either heck I wouldn't even have a
good content creation platform if the
lower was all straight forward well the
script at this point is about half of a
typical lower video for me and i know
mine on exact ramble feelings aren't the
best for a long detailed video so i
think this is good if you have any ideas
and what other videos you want before
the dlc comes out please let me know in
the comment I'm open to suggestions and
we've got a good amount of time before
the dlc comes out so I'm happy to make
videos that you guys want to see if I
haven't looked hope you enjoy the video
and I'll see you in the next one peace
out